we look back upon our journey and we we
dream about the future
the family tree is changing yeah and
it's and it starts right now
it started eight years ago really with
us and I grew up in a home too that
didn't really talk about money
necessarily or teach about finances and
all that sort of stuff I really didn't
know how to manage my money well my name
is Justin Wenzel this is my wife Kelly
you know we've been married eight years
but obviously our journey began far
before then I actually grew up in in
Kalamazoo Michigan my family grew up
here my parents have a business here
I was actually previously married before
I was with Kelly
unfortunately we went our separate ways
we would argue about things that didn't
have dollar signs attached to them but
we're totally connected to finances the
turning point for me was was going
through that divorce and just hitting
rock bottom for myself and I knew I knew
right then and there that when that
ended that that that's not how I wanted
to do it if God would give me the
opportunity to do it again I knew that I
wanted something to change a couple
years after my divorce
I began looking for that godly woman
again I knew after our first date that
that was it I knew that he was the one
for me I knew that God had sent him to
be mine and so yeah we didn't waste any
time once God puts two people together
we just go with it and so we had both
been normal up to this point I was
blessed that my parents took care of my
schooling for me so I didn't have a
bunch of student loans but I had credit
cards and I had credit cards that were
maxed out and then Kelly student loans
and a car loan that were coming with me
into our marriage then Justin had asked
for the Total Money Makeover book for
Christmas which I got for him not really
knowing anything about it and he said
would you like to read this it said of
course you know I'd love to read it so
we got engaged and read the book and
decided that we wanted to make progress
in our finances from the get-go because
ultimately we had decided that we wanted
a family and I wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom we needed to make a
plan so that I could do that that was
the beginning of our journey was the
book and so at that point we kind of
started doing our own individual budgets
before we got married
and then once we got married we
obviously joined everything together and
then started doing a joint budget and
you know looking back on our journey I
just I remember how it felt like we were
sacrificing everything when we first
started it was interesting for me the
initial phase wasn't so hard it was the
two and three years down the road when
you've been doing this for a while and
you know there's still things that that
we would like to do or just things that
we want to spend money on we have those
desires just like everybody else
we're not different than anybody else we
just have a piece of paper that tells us
no and you know sometimes it's nice
having a piece of paper tell you know
then versus having to tell your spouse
no we had to prove to ourselves that we
could live on just my income before we
could make the leap and really jump out
of the workplace for Kelly right
buddy you're into our marriage then we
found out we were pregnant with our
first son and through your family's
business they don't offer health
insurance and so our first son was born
in 2010 we were married 2008 since two
years in and a year later in 2011 we
were debt-free for the first time pretty
soon after we were debt-free we found
ourselves with the child in the hospital
every two years we have one that goes in
the hospital so another kid goes in the
hospital went from debt free to back
into death and thankfully always okay
that's what matters and so then we
fought our way back out again that kind
of made the debt snowball go a little
slower with that expense but we've made
it work I am so blasted Matt Kelly I'm
so blessed that that we have the same
goals and the same dreams and we want
the same things for our family I can I
just I couldn't even imagine where we'd
be I guarantee we've been going on
vacations on credit cards I guarantee I
mean we'd have 20 grand in credit card
debt I know for sure of that we wouldn't
have paid that it's still my school
loans
that's right to be honest why would we
have paid them off early right we can
make the payments let's just keep them
perfect we find ourselves now on baby
step three and starting to see the bank
account grow and looking at our future
through teaching financial piece classes
and just in our marriage our dream has
always been to give and we're really
starting able to dream about how can we
give and bless others the way that we
have been blessed through our journey
being able to give unexpectedly and
watching someone's reaction is one of
the most fun things that we have ever
done with money where we've come in
these last eight years have been nothing
short of a miracle quite honestly from
where we started you know previous to
being married and previous to even
knowing each other to where we are now
we oftentimes still sit there in awe of
three beautiful little kids and and in
just a wonderful family relationship and
just being able to meet our obligations
each month and I can't imagine being
able to do that really without having
gone through financial piece and really
without having read the book and gotten
together on our finances and really
having that shared dream and goal and
vision for our family and wanting the
same things and so you know just looking
back it's just been such a blessing and
anyone else that is interested in in
having even a piece of what we have it's
not about us it's not about something
that that we did that was special and
miraculous but just watching God work
and watching him work through us and
through Dave's teaching has has just
been a fantastic journey and something
that we're blessed to be a part
you